du côté du gouvernement et je veux pas
me lancer dans une joute verbale ou en
team pons par médias interposés avec nos
propres ne dérange pas de parler dans
sauvagement de la société parce que
c'est une réalité tout simplement vous
évoquez ce qui s'est produit depuis cet
été moi je me suis rendu aux obsèques
par exemple de monsieur philippe guillot
ce conducteur de bus de bayonne
exactement qui a été frappé à mort par
plusieurs individus auxquels il avait
demandé de payer un ticket de porter un
masque etc
je vois pas comment expliquer à ses
collègues que finalement ce n'est pas de
l'ensauvagement et qu'on ne souhaite pas
dénoncer ce fait avec de tels mots
maintenant je crois qu'au delà des mots
ce qui est inventé c'est l'action qui
est menée il ya une action très
solidaires entre eric dupond moretti et
gérald darmanin pour que la chaîne
pénale retrouve finalement son
efficacité